entering his 11th year in the NFL coming
off of arguably his best year as a
professional first-team all-pro 14 and a
half sacks last season three forced
fumbles last season those are career
highs for the Jacksonville Jaguar
calanis Campbell how are you colitis I'm
living the dream baby you are what does
that dream look like gimme a gimme paint
the word picture class man when I was a
kid I used to dream about like playing
in the NFL and all the things that were
going to that you know this is what I
imagined it really this is even better
than I imagined you know this is the
best slice in the wrong at the best job
around great guys and we have a chance
to win that makes me feel a lot better
too so I take a plane at all last last
season looking back on it how would you
rate it
how would you term it categorize it we
we had a lot of fun but you know we fell
short you know I realize but I got here
last year we went through our series an
hour never went to training camp I knew
we had a good chance to be a team that I
actually were in the Super Bowl
and so when we wouldn't along didn't
better players and you know got to the
NFC Championship game you know just
feels like you know just a little
incomplete you know cuz I felt like we
had a good chance you know last year and
but the cool thing about it is you're
always get another chance so we have
another opportunity sir
and I'm looking forward to start trying
to take advantage of yeah well before we
turn the page to to this year I mean how
often do you think about how last year
ended Elias to me just a little bit
throughout the offseason I thought about
a lot you know it's kind of you know I
told me during my training you know and
I want to drop a little way and try to
be a little faster because and I play
more D in you know didn't even I really
expected they told me they were gonna
play me a DA through the end whenever
you know it's trying to get me to come
in and recruit me but I kind of I
believed in glad I believed them as much
you know because you know us I'm gonna
play a little bit well I'm gonna move
around a lot you know and I did that but
I put a lot more DN did I played inside
and that was kind of surprising so just
a little way trying to get a little
faster so I can make a few more plays on
it and in terms of last year I don't
know if you were away
the fact that the head coach of the
Philadelphia Eagles has written a book
and Doug Peterson's written a book
called fearless and one of the excerpts
that were released this week prior to
the release of the book was him watching
the AFC Championship game prior to his
NFC Championship game against the
Vikings watching your team the Jaguars
take a knee at the end of the first half
quote I was there thinking you've got to
be kidding me right now
I was mad because Jacksonville had New
England right where they wanted them I
was screaming at the TV in my office
when they knelt right before half-time
inside I was like I'll never do that
what do you think of when you hear that
culeros you know after the day we win
the game
you know it never you know it doesn't
become a big deal but when you lose the
games and everybody you know says what
they say and you know believe that you
know we could've done things differently
you know and you know we know we learned
from all the different mistakes we made
throughout the game and some of the
stuff that we did well you know we've
learned just continue to do that kind of
stuff again so but you know I have
nothing but respect for you know
everybody who does well in this game
gosh we'll put the dedication put the
time in to be great and you can sell
that he's been I'm gonna eat on a Super
Bowl you know he's a Super Bowl winning
coach and he has done a good job
preparing his guys and everybody I know
who plays in Philadelphia less platform
so you know he seems like a really good
coach you know and we have a good thing
going on in this locker room and we like
our coach a lot too you know we all
bought into you know his formula no I
just plan to win and it's fully paid off
so I think you know nice to try to get
back in a situation again and see if we
can get to the top on in terms of doing
that you've got a big one against the
Giants to start the season and week one
with Eli Manning back there I have Nate
solder topping a list of Lyman I want to
ask you if you think they suck or not
colitis can I go down one by one I was a
pretty good player you know I try to
give him a few times in me the Colorado
native so you know I've always followed
his career because there's not many of
us in the NFL
so you know I've always rooted form and
you know I'm you see I'm getting a big
contract and end up in New York okay I'm
looking forward to playing - Justin
though you know especially you know guy
this high paid as he is and you know
it's always good to go just the best and
see where you stand so the whole the New
York Giants did a good job bringing in a
lot of talent they brought in one of our
guys - from last year Patrick O'Malley
and I used a good player too so there's
really tried to sit on our line this
year so our sugars are the ordeal and in
my opinion you know four more times so
I'm looking forward to trying to
challenge you know what they did full
disclosure
Calathes Campbell I did not really want
to know whether you thought Nate solders
sucked or not that was my way of getting
to jaylen Ramsey's gentlemen quarterly
conversation what did you think of the
GQ article how did that land in your
locker room hilarious it was
entertaining to say the least you know
we like to uh you know we all have like
a really tight-knit circle you know
we're all really close and you know we
have a lot of confidence and I've asked
one thing that drives us we believe that
we can be really good and I think
everything starts with the police and so
you know and I locker room we get to you
know mess around with it over there and
talk is you know we have some really
like really cool conversations and you
know generally the guy who is probably
one of most confident do you know to
lock the service you know I think I'm
pretty confident myself you know and so
you know yeah you know yeah he's very
opinionated you know and I picked he
says there are some things that he
really feels inside and I'll finish this
is something that's special that most
people want when you looking so Ashley
you want to know when I what he's
thinking you know what station what what
he goes through you know and he gives it
his all you know I'm kind of guys a
little more reserved you know and
there's nothing wrong with it or you
know I feel like after that day you know
the only thing you'll think about is you
know if guys are gonna be more you know
focused when I plant you but in a day
you know we're just you're you don't
expect him to be a big dog on a blog
talk about one of Super Bowls
everybody's all play the best game
against you or want to play the best
time against you they're gonna come with
bullseye on your back so when you go to
the heritage ampionship game you know
you kind of get that bullseye on your
back you know people on the residents of
the district so we already have that so
you know my mind you know uh you know
we're gonna talk a lot of trash and then
we go back it up well you know I I
preface what I'm about to go down by
saying I do love Jalen Ramsey and and I
had fun sitting one row in front of him
at the NFL honors last year and
reminding him of my positioning in the
seating chart and had some fun with him
and thankfully he took it in the proper
way but I do want to say this one way in
which Jalen Ramsey has not tested every
single week Callay Asst is if you get
home in time and put the quarterback on
his behind and in that response of
respect are you concerned that Ramsey's
writing some checks about some of these
quarterbacks that some of the linemen
who are as you know on the planet to
protect said quarterback you're gonna
have to cash that check Elias oh I'm not
worried at all not even a little bit you
know I mean we like to that's our mo
that's our motivator Slash's we talk
trash and me and you you know we like to
back it up you know I mean you got on
the list you know we have guys Jalen
Ramsey you know tell Miss Smith
you know Malik Malik Jackson this is I'm
itchin got quite I mean these guys love
talking trash you know where you see
them when you watching the games they're
going back and forth the whole time and
and I love I love just been a part of it
you know as long as I said Mononoke no
penalties you know no cars no issues but
as long as you you know talk to Travis
we're gonna continue to back it up you
know and I think that kind of drive
since it gives us the extra motivation
and as far as like you know you know
this attend game you know what goes hand
to hand you know and so on the back end
they give us a split second you know
we're going to make a lot more players
you know but we're get up to a
quarterback they're gonna throw the ball
a little quicker and they're gonna make
a lot more players and it goes hand in
hand so you know we have a good thing
going with our secondaries talented as
they are and in our deal on I saw that
we are you know we take turns making
plays and our linebackers are just too
talented to so I mean that's why I'm
very confident and when I talk about the
season because I'm really excited about
what we can do what kind of teller we
have on this defense well there's no
doubt you are so talented
there's no question about that
and you know it's difficult as you know
entering year 11 that when you're not
allowed to sneak up on some people it
makes things more difficult
what about the concept from those
outside looking in that the suspension
of Ramsey and Dante Fowler that this is
an issue that maybe from within that you
guys have a problem let alone the target
that's gonna be on your back now that
you've made the AFC Championship game
and they know they know not just seeing
on film they know what they're gonna get
from the Jaguars Elias no need to no
need to worry at all we have a really
just a close-knit group everybody you
know I mean obviously you know families
have issues and you know all that kind
of stuff is kind of you know be some ups
and downs don't have some adversity
that's just natural that's part of the
game but we're very close to that group
and you know and we really do a good job
you know just staying with each other
you know and trying to you know pick
each other up in so we have no issues at
all we handle you know any issues that
you know I might have been there and we
have no worries rubies as far ok
collects Campbell here on the Rich Eisen
show so year 11 now that you're you're
in this part of your career and you have
an opportunity you are on a Super Bowl
contending team of that there is no
doubt Elias what is your goal this year
period end of story
the goal is to win a big game you know
that's only go you know nothing else
matters no matter how many stats or
anything else is what I'm gonna be doing
and then going to Atlanta and hoisting
that trophy essentially yeah I want to
labardi trophy in my hands that's I want
to no matter
visualize when I go to sleep so
hopefully we can make it happen
hopefully can make it happen what do you
think of you open it up against LSU
coming up in a couple Sundays at 18 to
say tell me about it
I'm a I'm gonna be glued to my TV
watches you know I've always you know we
always wanted to show it to hang with
anybody so when you see us Effie and O
cross denim so I saw it's fun to watch
mmm and it was kind of a you reunion on
ballers right class the rock showed a
lot of love you know that was pretty
cool to do alright you know he was I
think he was uh
SAP's roommate at the U if I'm not
mistaken
are you wearing that yeah yeah but you
know sap is definitely uh you know Big
Brother tool that's except even after
he's a big brother to SAP but you know
yeah that whole you family's member all
tight-knit man everybody feels like
everybody loves so it's fun to be a part
of that family for sure
Calathes thanks for joining appreciate
it good luck down the line tell jaylen
we said hi okay what a seriously this is
what I'd like you to do okay and I'm
serious please do this class
alright I'm going to check to see if you
did this or not go to jail and Ramsey
tell him that we chatted okay and tell
him that if he's ever approached by any
magazine asking which on-air hosts suck
or not I better be at the top of the not
suck list I'm very sensitive and just
make sure he understands where we stand
with each other okay okay I gotta know
thanks class Campbell's got my back
you're on the Richardson show the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience